so you only have so much screen time
here so I was curious in your research
is there anything you learned about
colette and willie that didn't make it
into the final cut of the movie but you
hope that people know about them our
poker dancing yeah we learnt to poker
and we weren't very good at it and it
didn't make film so there you go I still
got to dance yeah I did do some dancing
but that one that one got caught out but
I don't feel like anything else got
caught out actually or wasn't there from
that no it was just my dancing oh I feel
like if that footage exists anywhere we
need to have it as like a blu-ray extra
or something sure you do you need to
yeah um curious to hear your answer to
this because I I hope my review winds up
justifying people going to see it with
this mentality but what would you say to
someone who looked at the poster or the
trailer just a little piece of marketing
and said oh another period drama I don't
need that in my life why should anybody
who kind of scoffs at that go to see
this movie I mean it's kind of like a
Trojan horse of a movie because you
think it's that and then it just kind of
goes right off on another tangent you
know I mean this is a film basically
about gender identity sexual politics
feminism about a woman finding her own
voice about an extraordinary kind of
celebrity couple you know who were
grabbing at Fame and I mean there there
it felt and what I loved about the
script was that it just felt so modern
and relevant and current and yeah it was
set a hundred years ago it's crazy how
it all Alliance to because I know you've
finished filming this before the me to
have been really kicked off so it just
seems like such perfect timing now so
how is it not knowing that that was
really going to happen while you were
shooting it and then seeing kind of the
world and the state of the industry that
this movie is coming into now I mean it
you know it I think the reason that it
finally could get made after what had
been trying to make it for 15 years was
because you know suddenly just in the
last 10 years we've been able to talk
about the women's movement we've been
able to talk about feminism again in a
way that we hadn't before that so I
think the fact that people were ready to
kind of
say yes we're interested in this woman
were interested in this topic was kind
of an indication of where the kind of
conversation was going I mean yeah
obviously I don't think anybody expected
the me to movement to happen in the way
that it did and that the conversation
would get you know would would would
sort of speed up in the way that it has
so it does feel like a very appropriate
sort of film for that but you know just
I just think she's cool and like you
know as a woman I'm just I want to see
my heroes I want to be like ah I feel
inspired and empowered by you and I did
I felt like that learning about her I
felt like that playing her and I hope
people will feel like that watching I
certainly felt like that watching yeah
there's also curious just because of the
comparison between Claudine and Colette
in your careers
have you ever had a role that just felt
like when you look back on it it really
represents where you were at that point
in your life I mean I always won far
beyond it but I don't think I was but
you know I really I find lots of pass
that care is played represent what I do
certain points in my life Anna Karenina
[Music]
[Music]